Hãy tìm nhấn tập đỏ sĩnh hàng đầu của nhận không còn nhận bằng cấp.
Quoi bằng cấp lại, thì tươi đẹp thăm thảo mà thôi.
Tình ở tất là lương giống như người mới vào.
Đi, mà cũng không có vào vinh chế được thì...
Nó như tuy nhập độc như giám xuống còn nữa.
Thế thầy những đó khoảng 2 đầu năm khoảng 2 năm để xấu thì...
người ta vẫn chưa chấp nhận người đứa đứa ngoài là như quyết thức.
Đặc quyết là những tập đồng, 2 trong đường mới làm được trở về càng không có tìm hơn.
Anh có tìm, cầy, thì viên dụng nào, khiến hợp,
có ý màu thế định chế nguyễn.
Nguyễn kê cầu nói, vướng mẹnh cũng như người,
đến chợi, bằng cấp thì là thầng cám mà thôi.
Bình thật cũng đúng như mày cho đến ngày, mình chúng mình được cái nơi,
thì mặc hết bánh năm để thiệt, mà mà mọi em tĩ chợi.
Sẽ, tốt hơn, thì chơi với người phương thảo rồi.
Bột lần nữa là phương phật rồi,
kiến hành, liền cứu tập vào thông tình giải quyết phân đệ nó với quan càng.
Dải quyết thứng miên có thang đẹp và diệu trên những cái kỹ này.
Mọi người đã qua thấy hiện như thế nào.
Vì hợp đỏ ở giá viên cái tình nè thôi
Nhưng mà mình có hí Trung tên
mà có hí hành có hí hành có hí hành
có hí hành có hí hành là mình không
Thá hương động hôn kế cái mà ở giá mình là
Mình chứ mình bằng những cái phát mình
Thá đặc quý
Mà đến bây giờ
Đà bóng nàn chú dụng